line segments I end this segment i n
over here and T oh this is T oh here are
reflected over the line y is equal to
negative X minus 2 so this is the line
that they're reflected about this dashed
purple line and it is indeed y equals
negative X minus 2 this right over here
is in slope-intercept form the slope
should be negative 1 and we see that the
slope of this purple line is indeed
negative 1 if X changes by a certain
amount and Y changes by the negative of
that if X changes by 1 Y changes by
negative 1 to get back to that line if X
changes by positive 2 y changes by
negative 2 to get back to another point
on that line and the y-intercept we see
when X is equal to 0 Y should be
negative 2 when X is equal to 0 Y is
indeed negative 2 so we validated that
now to say draw the image of this
reflection using the interactive graph
all right so we can move these lines
around and we want to reflect these and
I could try to eyeball it you know maybe
it's something like this I don't know it
doesn't seem exactly right that looks
close to the reflection of I N and for
tio I'd want to move this down here tio
looks like it would be I don't know I'm
i balling it this is close but I can't
be close I want to get exact
so let's I've copied and pasted the
original problem on my scratch pad so we
can find the exact points and so I don't
I don't just have to estimate this so
let's go to the scratch pad so exactly
what we just saw and the main
realization is is if we want to reflect
a given point if we want to reflect a
given point say point I right over here
what we want to do is we want to drop a
perpendicular we want to find a line
that's perpendicular a line that has the
point I on it and it's perpendicular to
this line right over here remember this
is this is the line let me do this in
the purple color this is the line y is
equal to negative X minus 2 its slope
its slope is equal to negative 1 so I
want to a line that goes through a point
I that has a that is perpendicular
perpendicular to this line and I want to
drop it I want to drop it to I want to
drop it to the line that I'm going to
reflect on and then I want to go the
same distance on to the other side to
find
to find the corresponding point in the
image so how do I do that well if this
line if this purple line is a slope of
negative one a line that is a line that
is perpendicular to it a line that is
perpendicular to it so this thing that
I'm drawing in purple right over here
it's slope is going to be the negative
reciprocal of this so the reciprocal of
negative one is still just negative one
one over negative one is still negative
one but we want the negative of that so
the slope here needs to be one and
luckily that's how I drew it the slope
here needs to be equal to one which is
however much I change in the X direction
I change in the Y direction we see that
to go from this point to this point
right over here we decrease Y by four
and we decrease X by four now if we want
to stay on this line to find the
reflection we just do the same thing we
could decrease X by four so we're go
from negative 2 to negative six and
decrease Y by four and we end up at this
point right over here so we end up at
the point this is x equals negative 6 y
is equal to negative 4 so this is this
point corresponds to this point right
over there
now let's do the same thing let's do the
same thing for point N for point n we
already know if we drop a perpendicular
if this is perpendicular it's going to
have a slope of 1 because this purple
line has a slope of negative 1 the
negative reciprocal of negative 1 is
positive 1 and let's see to go from this
point to this point of intersection we
have to go down 1 and 1/2 we're going
down 1 and 1/2 and we're going to the
left 1 and 1/2 so we want to do that on
the other side we want to stay on this
perpendicular line so we want to go left
1 and 1/2 and down 1 and 1/2 and we get
to this point right over here which is
the point x equals 3y is equal to
negative 8 and so we are now equidistant
we're on this perpendicular line still
but we're equidistant on the other side
so the image of I N is going to go
through negative 6 comma negative 4 and
3 comma negative 8 so let me let me draw
that so let me see if I can remember
negative 6 negative 4 3 comma negative 8
so I have a bad memory so negative six
negative four and three comma negative
eight and I was close when I estimate it
but I wasn't exactly right so that's
looking that's looking pretty good
and then actually we can do the exact
same thing with points T in point O and
let me do that so point T at the point t
to get from point T to the line in the
shortest distance once again we drop a
perpendicular this line is going to have
a slope of 1 because it's perpendicular
to the line that has a slope of negative
1 and so to get there we have to
decrease our X by we have to decrease
our X we're going from x equals 5 to x
equals looks like 1/2 so X went down by
4 and 1/2 in the X direction and Y also
needs to go down by 4 and a half so if
we want to stay on that line let's
decrease our X by 4 and a half so that's
1/2 1 2 3 4 and Y needs to go down by 4
and a half so that's 1/2 1 2 3 4 and we
get to this point right over here which
is the point x equals negative 4 y is
equal to negative 7 negative 4 comma
negative 7 let me so this should be at
negative 4 y equals negative 7 and
there's a couple of things you could do
here you could just say this is too long
this is our two units long not like too
long in length somehow this is two units
long so maybe this is two units long so
this is feeling good pretty good let's
just go through the exercise 4.0 as well
so point o once again this is going to
have if we drop a perpendicular it's
going to have a slope of 1 so whatever
our change in X between this point and
this point we're gonna have the same
change in Y and our change in X to go
from 7 to 7 to one and a half our change
in X is five and a half so maybe let me
do it this way so the change in X here
so a change in X is equal to negative 5
and 1/2 5.5 if you subtract 5.5 from 7
you get to 1.5 and our change in Y our
change in Y is also negative 5.5 change
in Y is negative you're not going to see
that something too different
negative 5.5 and so we need to stand on
this line so we want to change by those
same amounts on to the other side of
that line so if we decrease our X by 5
and 1/2 so 1/2 1 2 3 4 5 we get there
and Y by 5 and 1/2 hat 1/2 1 2 3 4 5 we
get to the point x equals negative 4 y
is equal to negative 9 so we get to the
point x equals negative 4 y is equal to
negative 9 and we're done we have
figured out the reflection of these two
of these two segments